the democrats and many on the left
worked around the clock to kill brett
Cavanaugh's nomination to the Supreme
Court but I think they made a fatal
miscalculation they thought it was okay
along the way to jettison the principle
of due process and use victims to pursue
a radical political agenda and on this
first year anniversary of the me2
movement I think it's important to
remember that this all started with
liberal Democrat Harvey Weinstein friend
of Bill and Hillary's and of course
Barack Obama and remember he's a
Hollywood mogul big mega donor I mean
this guy is where it all happened and
remember the abuse there started the
cultural moment of me to this notion of
objectifying women and using them for
the pleasure of the powerful has been
long nurtured by the left at the same
time they're like oh we're so Pro women
as we abuse women on the casting couch
etc and the entertainment industry had
the target on its back but now we see
the same mentality at play in the
Cavanagh struggle for other claims to be
defenders of women the Democrats
cynically
and I think cruelly used Kristine Ford
in a desperate attempt to derail a
Supreme Court nominee remember she
didn't initially want to come forward to
tell her story she was dragged into the
open by political leaks to the
Washington Post and other media outlets
and remember reporters surrounded her
home and then she was forced to tell her
story and today we learned of more dirty
tricks from these activists lawyers
behind the scenes
remember Leland Kaiser she was the
person who Ford claimed was at the party
where Cavanaugh allegedly assaulted her
one of her close friends
well Kaiser previously told the Senate
committee that she didn't know of such a
party and didn't even know Cavanaugh to
begin with today though she told the
Wall Street Journal that in that in the
FBI that a former agent another friend
of Christine Ford and Monica McLain
pressured her to change her account to
corroborate
Ford's account unbelievable well in a
speech announcing her decision to vote
for Cavanaugh's confirmation today
senator Susan Collins perfectly summed
summed up the callousness of the
Democrats some people who wanted to
engineer the defeat of this nomination
cared little if at all for her
well-being
professor Ford testified that a very
limited number of people had access to
her letter yet that letter found its way
into the public domain and today Dianne
Feinstein left no doubt as to what this
nasty senseless battle was really all
about all along the left desire to use
the supreme court to impose liberal
social values on society another issue
that gives me great pause is judge
Cavanaugh's extreme view on guns the
challenging realities women face roe v--
wade what kind of medical care you can
receive well this has been a problem for
decades the American Left believes the
court should be kind of a super
legislature a body that makes law rather
than interprets law since Trump
announced his candidacy to the
presidency the left has been in
perpetual rage mode and of course this
continued into the night and it's going
to go on for some time and this is how
they attempted to influence Susan
Collins before she announced her vote
check it out
[Music]
oh nice and this is how they work their
charms on Democrat Joe Manchin after he
announced he was supporting Cavanaugh
least it's a one-word chant it's easy to
follow you know what's really shameful
Democrats who use victimhood as their
defining principle then rather have
people dependent on government helpless
without it especially certain groups
minorities immigrants and even women
we're supposed to believe that we can't
survive and thrive without an activist
court making up new rights finding them
in the Constitution and they demand that
we believe anyone who claims victim
status we have to take them at their
word regardless of where the facts lie
but for all their screaming and their
tiresome chanting the left's basically
come up empty this time most Americans
don't see themselves as victims
we're not powerless or weak we're strong
and independent
this was the Democrats miscalculation
they thought emotional extortion and
protester histrionics would be enough to
block a well qualified Supreme Court
nominee but once again they let their
rabid political ideology blind them to
the fact that Americans are fair-minded
have a basic goodness about them and
they're optimistic about the future
they don't need an activist Supreme
Court to see the light to know where we
are as a people to see our future and
that's the angle